par 3 132 votes pour et 87 voix contre
la majorité des deux tiers est attentes
le projet de loi est donc adopté les
objections du président sont donc
rejetées
le greffier va aviser le sénat de
l'action de la chambre
par ce vote la chambre des représentants
rejettent le veto de donald trump au
prochain budget de la défense et fait un
nouveau pas vers l'adoption de ce texte
si cette nuit le sénat où les
républicains détiennent une courte
majorité rejettent aussi ce veto ce sera
une grande première sous le mandat de
donald trump est un camouflet inédit
jusqu'ici les deux chambres n'ont jamais
réuni assez de votes pour outrepasser le
veto présidentiel déposé à huit reprises
depuis quatre ans cette fois ci l'enjeu
semble transcender les oppositions
partisanes
le président trump a noté à juste titre
que le budget de la défense présentée
cette année n'inclut pas toutes les
mesures que nous républicain aurions
voulu je ne doute pas que nos collègues
démocrates pensent la même chose mais
c'est le cas chaque année on les
courageux hommes et femmes des forces
armées des états unis l'échec n'est
simplement pas une option
donc lorsque c'est à notre tour au
congrès de les soutenir
nous ne pouvons pas échouer j'encourage
mes collègues à soutenir ce budget une
nouvelle fois lorsque nous voterons
demain le président américain refuse ce
budget car il permet le changement de
nom de base militaire honorant des
généraux partisans de l' esclavage mais
aussi parce qu'il réduit la possibilité
de retirer des troupes américaines
d'afghanistan d'allemagne et de corée du
sud
comme souvent c'est par un tweet que
donald trump a marqué son désaccord
nos formidables soldats ne pourront pas
être retirés de pays étrangers qui ne
font rien pour nous négocié un meilleur
projet de loi où trouver de meilleurs
dirigeants maintenant le sénat ne
devrait pas approuver le budget de la
défense tant qu'il n'est pas améliorée
le vote du sénat aura lieu cette nuit
autre habitude donald trump à la veille
de ce vote crucial
il a été aperçu en train de se rendre
sur le parcours de golf qu'il possède en
floride